tens of millions of people turned out to
elect
local council leaders in the state of
uttar pradesh over four days in april
as india was recording the world's
highest number of coronavirus cases
now unions say 1600 teachers who were
forced to go on calling duty
have died from covet 19. that includes
neetu singh's husband rajiv who attended
this training session in muradhabad
on april 25th
he got infected with covert there he
suddenly felt sick and was struggling to
breathe
he told them he wasn't feeling well and
wanted to go home
he came home and in the evening and even
after saying
multiple times he was too sick to work
he was forced to work
the next day rajiv died from covert 19
12 days later uttar pradesh has been one
of the states
worst affected by the coronavirus
candidate
vedvati devi died after campaigning in
the villages of muratabad district
we were campaigning for her and suddenly
one day she complained about a headache
and later developed a fever next morning
we took her to chandasi where the doctor
asked us to take her to muradhavat city
but she died on her way to muradhabad
there was no oxygen at chandosi
but she couldn't reach muradhabad
the government in uttar pradesh says it
enforced covet 19 protocols such as
social distancing
and that only three teachers died from
the virus that's denied by the president
of the teachers association who told al
jazeera
the organization repeatedly asked the
government to call
off the voting as the number of teachers
becoming ill
increased
if someone has election duty and they
don't go they're absent
there can even be a criminal case in
action against them
they're under a lot of pressure says
many teachers who refused to take part
had their salary cut
and some remain suspended from work the
government has offered compensation to
the families of those it says died on
duty but
teachers associations say they must
first acknowledge the actual
number of lives lost elizabeth puranam
al jazeera new delhi